[Music]
this week we've got sound tattoo for
prize and network out taking a weary
Tiffany I like that an otherwise regular
okay it's over over sorry we have these
tattoos that can actually place them
home
what any song about I don't know how I
feel about it yet my friend that makes
sense because no tattoos have a purpose
how the [ __ ] does this happen is it like
a computer there or something or art so
I'm going to show you guys a video where
they show you how this all works
and I can do [ __ ] good so the way it
works is that these tattoos sound waves
on your body and then there's an app
that this company is developing to be
able to play that sound wave through the
app so here we go
beeps injects a lead into your body and
all it took to it and though I decided
that I wanted to get and my choice was
of my dog Bochy and he has a famous
towel that he does
so I decided to have picture of bocce
and that's awesome
wait she do a wave form tattoos on their
body and this is body and this is the
Saturday that's really cool oh I get it
now
that is awesome so if you guys don't
know wave forms when you're recording
audio like whether you're in the studio
making a beat or whatever it's that
thing that goes like this that you
always see all the producers like check
out my new [ __ ] beat fun and it's
like that's a waveform every single
sound in the universe has a waveform and
it's crazy that you can get a waveform
tattooed and now you could play it off
your skin and it's awesome that's my boy
it feels way different than when I was
the guinea kt2 thought it was like you
know how we did that article where
people put the microchip in yeah I
thought you put a microchip in the
people please a creator or music and
everyone have an implant an ad but it
would be a tattoo over it yeah because
this is really literal actually this is
almost like if you got like like the
lines like music notes you get any put
actual notes and then you get your phone
and you're scanning like ABC you like it
I gets like that I thought it's very
very literal as with the students so
this apical skew motion they're
releasing it in June they are saying
that the Apple grease free but you just
have to pay for the actual Tituba
getting and they'll be working with
specific tattoo artists across the
entire world only catch ours was
cleavage shows all the time they'll be
the only ones I'll be able to give you
sound repressive that's good because I
know tattoos to get um to get really
straight lines you have to be really
good and it's so surprising to see how
many tattoo artists can't make
well that game is so malleable mastani
but there's no there's people I can do
what have you accidentally tapped to a
waveform but then you're off by a couple
lines oh they just would like it was
supposed to say like I love you and this
is I [ __ ] you or something so the way
this works is that in the app you upload
the sound that you want and they'll
create an image for you and then that's
what you take to the specific tattoo
artists that are partnered with the
specific we gotta be good enough to do
the waveforms that yeah well from my
understanding it seems like that you're
already uploading the sound clip yeah so
I don't know if it really needs to have
a specific like lines I don't know too
much about that the actual technology
behind that and it doesn't even read it
just like pictures out it's literally
just a they just like upload it into I
guess whatever serial number is going to
like your profile that's what I'm trying
to get like I like that you don't really
need the actual line like I feel like me
you just play me what you have well a
bit like quote-unquote like whatever you
know how we have like face recognition
yeah that's it like a tattoo recognition
it is gold/black then dude that's why I
wanted it to have specific notes so you
could play your oh [ __ ] why I wasn't
enough but a gangsta ha they did mention
that they want to develop this
technology for like people that already
have the waveform tattoos for them to be
able to play what they already have
they're trying to develop an GD waveform
tattoos hmm
I don't know if it's not smarter done
right so so basically like in the future
G over here to get her tattoos like
Aidid in the system and she could also
have like her dogs you know going or
something yeah I wish my dog's held I
think it's weird to me because it's like
getting a tattoo of your polygraph test
you know like check it out this is the
1970s earthquake seismograph
so it's just it's just a weird thing to
me come ah so what's weird about it that
is a reading of something
nonsense so instead of doing a tissue
box like you know I'm mad at you tissues
keep this on my chest you're saying let
me get the heat sensor infrared vision
goggles of the tissue box on my chest so
now you have like red green yellow bars
and Alex always I don't know that's the
National Archives and for this is like
sound you can't really capture sound
that's true
or you could just say bark bark bark
that's true it's so different when you
say dumb [ __ ] and we're across from each
other so different I so far next story
everyone favorite restaurant here and
release all costly is a living do that
this new item called for arc because
that's all nobody works right for high
fort which restaurant what's your
favorite restaurant in the full run oh
really
we're talking about a lot of them the
most important one I don't act like you
know now it's okay oh it's okay I don't
like Miguel's oh my god finally haha and
this is the last episode you're going to
be like thank you very much for inviting
me on the show today I'm going to switch
the cabinet when he's gone okay by
yourself where Michael go alright so I'm
going to show you guys their promo video
for these words such a weird word to say
for yeah it's not even a McDonald's work
to be a mix something yeah I'm exploring
yes yes I was like what the [ __ ] dude
took a star tracker it sounds like a
monster Klan in Game of Thrones income
rise again and we will different well I
was a presentation for McDonald's
signature craft impressive slowed down
when a satirical that sort of looks of
what is a real advertisement stay tuned
hi Anthony Thomas real Donald Amanda
p.m. this looks like a parody video
flavors not realism Olli maple-bacon
Dijon is lovely barbecue bacon
but when savoring these recipes is heavy
real you just topped it
sorry oh my clothes - is it real pro
I've always wanted to do this before
actually reason for my good news we sold
it anyway Pico cuacamole wow you're
making with sweet maple Oh No whole
ghetto let me read on your baby
oh that's what I got strong ethos bad
yes that's what's gonna happen
Ludacris the hidden oklahoma design
makes it handy varieties and laughing
hybrid extras I wasn't usually like ARMA
Dexter so call one eight four former
people now to see how you could get on a
doing Hills rock quarry I'm also maybe
do some weight like a love music and
right here for free
doesn't say Thomas continues to raise
the bar all day I'm with Mike Latta
things are real hey this is so sacred
sacred girls would never put out an hour
- I like this at all you know there are
two it's professional for this can I
leave this so professionally can I just
owe production company what did you guys
see that that pseudo documentary film
founder no we're about to visit during
work it was on the flight to Hawaii
Oh while we're working I was working on
any working on a lot of shares taking a
lot of notes on what I'm business oh my
goodness
but anyways so did you know McDonald's
was stolen what do you mean it sounds
like some change in that one movie
that's gonna come out the founder
co-founder saw the the guy that we know
Kevin Costner no no Michael Keaton
Michael Keaton yeah same thing so like I
guess I didn't know if it was true or
embellish it's true so like I guess the
original founders of McDonald's were
these two brothers and there was this
man who came through who we know as the
owner of McDonald's that basically
Facebook so
that basically came in and he wanted to
help them franchise it or help but he
just needed something to do some
franchises out for them but they kind of
did stuff something through a handshake
so basically because he franchised like
a majority of the stuff I'm like
paraphrasing a really close but he's
basically took all of it away and [ __ ]
him over and didn't own anything at all
we took the whole franchise away from
the two brothers who started it and so
the brothers like main motive was to
make fast food that had quality so it
was like in and out originally how big
all was but then pretend it was like
it's not fast enough it's not quick
enough so the milkshake stopped being
real milk that he started using powders
and he started doing things more quick
and lowering the quality so they cutting
out the quantity does any cocaine to
everything no nothing thank you on that
one but but yeah it's a stolen idea so
now it makes me feel like I don't want
to support the dollar right but it's so
delicious
I do support in and out if that's what
you're trying to do I put your origins I
just wish in and out had the same
quality of fries
but they use real potatoes are I know
that's why I see it and out fries to me
though they're always going to be fresh
no matter what that's why I really like
it because that's but it's not like
cardboard if you get it in the first
five minutes no like the first comes
second they're amazing and then after
that there could you eat slow as [ __ ]
though what do you want you all real
[ __ ] real [ __ ] what do you want fake
[ __ ] that piece how do you even propose
that question when you like fake [ __ ]
what he's talking about is no better
everything finished she didn't let me
put the period on my surface I like
everything in case you don't know
[Laughter]
different one is right in front of your
Fela
now you understand we go this whole
thank God that way you love life that's
what you bring II never feel like that's
where you bring the [ __ ] movie bars
dude
what are you talking about how do you
even propose that question when you like
fake [ __ ] please talk about yes what
they're saying that there was a limited
supply of these for God's so it was
really real alittle ratings almost
actually made that commercial because
that looks like hella bootleg I mean if
it was like this cuz it was kind of like
a joke yeah like a Joe there making fun
of himself
or like the product itself but there was
a limited supply of these Forks that
they were available with the purchase of
one of their signature I guess there's
not enough [ __ ] in the United States it
was it was yeah
so it wasn't participating stores the
Beltway back on me sis I felt bunch of
my Facebook friends with it I'm like but
I will say this though because of your
guys's terrible origins I can no longer
support you and also because you sponsor
everybody besides us so you never get it
around this is a wall yeah I saw about
like honestly at this point like I know
like we joke about it a lot I say hey
McDonald's these clowns Wisconsin we
don't give a [ __ ] about this the last I
hold your [ __ ] horses alright sorry I
jumped the gun to boys I'm bad I'm
supporting you give you a cue ruble okay
huh
that is a last [ __ ] straw pulchio
McDonald
this is the real JK Nia's waffle did
their fake version of JK knows you
sponsor the fake
[Music]
but they know what's up I wish idea I
wish I had the [ __ ] Kermit the Frog
mograine oh yeah man that's a McDonald's
of you feelin other people's idea I'm
just we gotta work within a half that's
what we got do ya now super [ __ ]
wholesome though I know you know like
McDonald's it's paint Coulson yeah
things that there's a family bread even
though crackheads drug dealers
prostitutes all go there yeah and I on
the other hand is way different we gonna
thank you and we go there that's what
I'm saying that's why I don't like my
dogs right now because you guys a
[ __ ] face you guys a Chompy as
mothers who should we click up with this
call junior they got to the opossum
everybody's talked about oh can we do
did you try to chicken honey I know you
Wendy's chicken nuggets dude I'm telling
you Westside so [ __ ] good when I
can't actually be Ellen for the tweets
for the wind easement oh yeah yeah we
got them yeah you actually being crazy
what a [ __ ] moving on to the our last
story here so there's this gym in the UK
that are now offering master size class
please can I sign up for this gym what
is what is that now I'm gonna show you
guys their promo clip dude you should be
their coach you're good I am good you
know what this is
no just napping not snapping exercise Oh
own after extra of napping expose I'll
go through all of the other thing of the
you know the old file-sharing day or
Napster yeah we said that that's what I
thought I heard it but then I figured
nap everyone was like all right
oh I'm just like conversation buyer so
shut the [ __ ] up all right all right
let's watch this video look watch this
video
Oh
[Music]
hi guys welcome to not society
emphasizes reporter project design our
PD people on the taken titles alive
section every time how do you read I
might have about to say that I love the
concept of it if they dream kick I'm not
mean to do snore she come out I thought
the same thing so I'm like really gonna
do is people that will go in this word I
don't snore see what were you snore yeah
I was Hawking hate to the ECB Madine and
I snore together and it's a crazy
Symphony I heard really what it sound
like it's so funny tell you people are
so he does but if I'm knocked out and
I'm starting tikka still fall asleep and
if he's gone I could still fall asleep
I'm not interesting
I am a little bit here that she got used
to it though she she used to hate that
first but now she could sleep through
anything
mmm banning heretic it takes a while
even in college in a Riverside my
roommate Tony he hated it at first but
he told me later on
thank you because now he could sleep
through yeah it's pretty awesome I like
this concept and they have it in Japan
where you get those pot hotels no I hear
the 20 minute 30 minute nap and I think
that's better because when you go to
those Chinese massage places there's
always some guy falling asleep snoring
and then ruining everyone's experience
that's usually me when I met those
Chinese massage places I guess all
relaxed I start snoring and then I do
wake people up oh don't you ever wonder
though it's like if you're asleep and
they stop you know massage gee you're
not gonna get your fools money's worth
like I would worry
I feel the same way your so judge me
what are you gonna do drink a Red Bull
before you to massage oh my god I'm like
okay okay I'm getting really comfortable
you're not mindful how much had these
changes on you
these are like sixty dollars boy Ben
Peter this is supposed to be 20 bucks
Sam you sergeant nobody but I get the
one where it's like 90 minutes because I
want to let you know oh no no I don't
know no no but see how much riders
here's the problem with that so when
you're going into your massage right the
purpose of it is for you to be relaxed
so if you're constantly worried about
getting gypped that already defeats the
purpose of your massage so it makes more
sense for you to fall asleep and
relaxing that's what it's there for
if they help me fall asleep that means
you did a good [ __ ] job because
that's somebody help me but while
they're touching me
can you both be with somebody so I'm
saying so for me as long as I'm relaxed
I wake up and I'm extra relaxed with me
you did a little extra work okay it's
work
yeah but they're saying that these
classes are now fully losers yeah I love
this idea de sponge I'm like super tired
throughout the day and I'm like [ __ ] I
want to just take a nap and there's
nowhere to go because if you have to go
home and to go to traffic but if there's
a bunch of these locally like there are
McDonald's and I could just pull in into
a David Lloyd [ __ ] not to place and
that is out his anus open it up
so the David Lloyd is like a chain of
clubs yeah for David Moyes and I take a
little nap real quick and a comfortable
at bed BAM
do you want to pay this pay that speed
in that you know if it's like a control
holiday to have anything because I'll be
pretty cool like this air any anything
that I want if I can get it now I'm down
to pay for it because you know what the
cool thing is if they had as much
locations at a 24-hour I mean anywhere
you go and you just need to take a quick
nap yeah yeah
David Lloyd got you back how many times
have we had to sleep in a hot-ass car
and I should ain't comfortable that's
right yeah no matter how much I try to
lean back my seed and open up the trunk
and make it a comfortable sleeping space
it's not you'd be down in Texas master
Versailles class because they do 15
minutes of gentle stretching before you
get to either the general strategy is
either clothing I've anything I know
that's the thing I get this would be
even worth it for you since is that
15-minute stretching mechanism exists
hung on the back I'm sorry sleeping now
exactly he doesn't need to go to
calculus one and he's already there you
know then I use the equipment yeah how
much does this cost I couldn't find that
out and I tried checking the company
website but it just says that all maybe
occurs with the membership maybe yeah
that'd be awesome dude because I need to
learn how to sleep I wish it was more
japanese-style where you just rent a pod
hmm a little more privacy yeah it's just
super quiet a little bit have you guys
ever slept in those capsule things
before hmm
it's pretty I mean I've done it a couple
of times like I feel like it's small but
you still are able to kind of like you
know get up and go on your laptop but I
mean the thing with me is that like I
don't really if I go on a vacation
I don't really want to be in another
hostile situation like that just because
I feel like I want to be able to be
extremely loud you know when I want to
be in calm no no what I'm [ __ ] angle
it's like if I want to play music is
[ __ ] I got you that's what I want to do
Michael but I mean it's actually not as
small as what people seem to think and
it's actually quite comfortable
especially in Japan because you have
these really um I remember like at least
the hospitai was that having a memory
foam mattress not like it's not pretty
clean we got the only thing much cleaned
up you know what I don't like about
hostels is based on the fact that they
call it hostile it's like very negative
I don't know I just don't like that name
I wish they would change the name of
something out like gentle gentle
well it's spelt differently though yeah
but they're just trying to lightly skew
it and to trick you and it works yeah
hello JK news fans now I know you want
to be a part of our videos and you know
how you do that you go to the [ __ ]
link below and use [ __ ] submit some
articles other than that go check out
our videos up here
hell yeah
[Music]